okay you guys remember that imagined
thing that those celebrities did with
gal gadot she's I talk about all whites
less so embarrassing this need whites
others who are like we I take
responsibility for why I'm not forced a
you why he's gonna be long you guys
gonna help you look at all the you two
hun
could be good firm it dudes you know
what now that you said you take
responsibility white celebrity whoever
the [ __ ] you are
I bet I bet all the boys in the hood or
just breathing a sigh of relief guys
guys the Aaron Paul and all these other
actors are taking responsibility thank
God we're safe now
thanks a lot doctor no helps you [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] oh so what about this gin
well obviously I've the majority of
people agree with you guys as well do
anything yeah and so preacher face
himself Hollywood they've so
embarrassing we're all no did he
recreate one no no he was just talking
about it good he was terrible lack of
diversity in this video first of all
which is a joke and then I can't wait to
go bad on this in my stand-up this is on
right this is nothing wrote the thing
that bill just bit tired being lectured
dude nice always think the general
public needs to see my face they can't
get the cinema so I needed to do
something I agree that's when you look
in their eyes you know that even if
they're doing something good they're
sort of thing yet I could weep in I
could weave that what good a person I am
oh dear
it's so true you can totally tell
they're literally like don't forget
about me yeah I'm on it too you're using
a lot of this comic is posting this okay
this black lives thing like where where
were you a month ago where were you
doing the Kaepernick stuff where were
you where were you an eighty to a black
young black well actually a two black
people from Toddlers to the age of 74 go
were shot in Chicago in one weekend well
if you're all of a sudden Hollywood now
is like wait is this popular let me jump
on here and get myself on social media
your social media posts don't mean a
[ __ ] thing
they don't make anybody safer they don't
make any black lives better get the [ __ ]
out of here it's so condescending
it's so embarrassing I swear to god it's
what I said before it's like they're
literally like cats chasing a light beam
you go from one movement to the other
and then you lose interest like this is
my thing how does that know that this is
lame as [ __ ] how does it come so I out
of touch probably not know that this
isn't it because there are makers
I liked in the [ __ ] up black white
asian it's whoever you are nobody sees
goes out man powerful they're good Pete
yeah hey thanks a lot doing it you do us
so much thanks for standing for equality
like oh I stand for inequality thanks
for standing for peace and I stand for
war what the [ __ ] you said they're the
worst
you're the worst and they don't my
favorite actors I don't give a [ __ ]
about her who was that she was in the OJ
this guy these [ __ ] actors would with
trying to act like they give a [ __ ] it's
so embarrassing and whoever put this on
is a [ __ ] Yoker like if a bunch of
yo-yos
yeah bunch of done I don't give a [ __ ]
about any of them though you're all off
my Island out out but it was that guy
that's Justin Theroux my North Star was
that talked about that guy Oh easy do
you win a beanie - here get out of here
Oh easy Oh y'all get out of here
she's in there too which is a bummer
okay Kristen Bell is the voice of frozen
Sally raised in her past who's that girl
The Olympian girl very cute Aly Raisman
yeah yeah she's very sexy but I don't
give hey guys I get it guys though
or say actually it tasted a great
movement whites for blacks org I'm so
it's so it's so cringy I'll tell you
what and even black for like well Gooden
to go into the black community and find
children that don't have parents or in
the foster system and and raise them how
about that do everything you can to make
their lives better but you're not huh
that's no [ __ ] but that doesn't do
anything no this might upset oh it just
makes me hate Hollywood more I just so
embarrassing dude every Oscars is a new
the Oscars every Oscars a new class it
was transgender it's me too it's what it
thousands whatever the flavor of the
year is let's rip our mast off and get
into a group of a thousand now cuz
[ __ ] it was Ohio it's black how about
when I worked Oscars in they're like oh
you have to wear me to pin like I
remember that like no I don't yeah like
you have to if you're on the air I'm
like I'm not wearing it man yeah I don't
know enough detail I'm not into this
yeah
not that I'm want women to be raped I
don't know they're just it's right well
it's not that way I'm not wearing this
since I get more notified of it it's
only could make a change there if you
don't tow the line you you will get
boycott your business you looking at end
up where one but the point is is I gave
up a little fight yeah I put a little
fight you have I don't think I wore one
to be honest I went I went I'll wear up
because they want to it they're like
well we were a rose like yeah whatever
I'm not wearing a penises meet you on
yeah I'm not part of the problem right
it's embarrassing I think like I always
say I think that the net result at the
end of the day is gonna be the most the
ball for that sets us back that makes me
a chomps are going through a hard
[ __ ] time and as we always say on
this show
the majority of cops so when I walk into
the Phoenix stand up life this guy goes
oh dude big fan here's like this thing
on his wrist and it looked Milty I know
you know - yes
top you know tough times I'm I'm very
tough I had a Vegas kind of I'm sorry
yeah came to our show we have a lot of
cops were coming with him and and
obviously and I think everybody knows
this including people in the
movement that the majority of cops are
great people do a great you know there's
some power some power glass holes in
every group and they ruin it for
everybody
you have [ __ ] in every group and
they have to be held to account for sure
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]